uncircumcised oh yeah yeah I've told you
about that one yeah yeah yeah you saw
that on PVD right I did what the [__] is
going on yeah I blew my blew my mind
yeah explain uncircumcised uh
yeah it's just a stupid word there's
just no point for the word yeah it's
just it's circumcising that's what I was
saying yeah we don't we don't call
things ungay you know what I mean but
this is the joke that I was trying to
make it was It was obviously with all
the Kanye stuff and the you know Jews
being controlled the media so in my mind
I'm like all right what's the funniest
way where I can make the argument that
Jews do control the media and then I
thought about uh the the and I was like
yeah I'm circumcised well I have a
Jewish I'm not Jewish but I might
because Jewish and uh that seems pretty
good control
I was in the car with a friend a couple
of weeks ago and his girlfriend was sat
next to me we were talking about this
exact thing yeah and she went uh honey
uh close your eyes for a second yeah I
have seen a lot of in my life yeah I
have never seen one that's got a
foreskin and I was like wow if you're in
the UK you would have struggled to see
one that didn't have a foreskin yeah in
fact if you're Brian you have too much
like you've got way more than you need
90 foreskin yeah he could use it as a
burqa like but he's coming over there
he's gonna do he's gonna when he becomes
my son he's gonna get circumcised step
into it like a sleeping bag that's what
that's for his new Pride bro that's for
his new Pride oh Brian but yeah yeah
it's a it's not it's a fascinating term
it's just yeah getting yeah it's such a
weird thing why is it that so many
Americans are Jewish circumcised
um why what is Kanye's answer no uh no I
think I think it became like a health
thing at one point like people thought
it was healthier I've looked it up a
little bit but it is like it is an odd
tradition right and what's so
interesting about it is the way that
women perceive it like women
in America are
I don't want to say repulse but they're
not into the the whole thing intact yeah
yeah yeah and um
it is it's just it is a fascinating
thing that like you could create
perception and create a aversion to
something that is natural yeah like the
way it's supposed to look you know even
now yeah like I'm like mine looks better
yeah you know but that was Bill MOS take
Bill what is that it just said that it's
it's so ugly I'm like well that's kind
of the same as saying like someone that
hasn't chopped an arm off is is more
more ugly but it's so you're so right
about it being like a cultural
conditioning thing yeah this is what
you're used to or what you think and
there's some sort of like predisposition
around editing things does make them
better you're taking away so here's his
thing we do that all the time right we
take away fat you look better you know
we we add jawline we do these other
things I'll get into the meat and
potatoes of it uh you have a gossamer
thin amount of tissue yeah on the Corona
of the penis yeah right yeah that's is
protected by the foreskin or the bell
end as we call it in the UK yeah like
that brilliant insult calling someone a
bell and it's so satisfying
um you get like keratinized balance over
time like the head of the penis becomes
like so you've got I can only imagine
that Jewish women have got to like in
oh in order to lose his sensitivity ABS
100 loses sensitivity there is a huge
movement online that says male
circumcision is gentle mutilation for
boys because it down regulates the
amount of pleasure that they can get and
isn't that good because maybe our women
come more because of it because you can
last longer yeah interesting I'd love to
see someone do a study on this please we
gotta do a study really good how many
pumps can how many pumps because you
guys are so sensitive you're busting all
early and we're out here just you know
smashing hips just smashing hips dude we
really might be that's a great Point
shout out the Jews the Jews knew that
it's the most feminist thing that
they've done the Jews knew the Jews knew
that women need an orgasm we need to
desensitize these they just had them out
there in the desert just dragging along
the sand and eventually it got to the
point where they're just making their
women come none stop this is brilliant
this is true it's like someone's chopped
the end off a baseball bat and it's just
dangling down there that's it it's rock
hard piece so yeah but think about it if
it's helping the women out and help what
is the most embarrassing thing as a guy
it's coming tonight too soon yeah yeah I
think they should have chopped more of
mine off because I stay clean early
stuff I think I only got like a half can
I take a bit more off the top please get
off my boy that is so true short back
insides please yeah so is it super
sensitive for you well I don't know I
haven't got nothing to compare it to
yeah it's a dick yeah so I think like
yeah like when it comes out is it like
cold like oh
not usually temperature checked I'll
check next time but like when you talk
it back do you feel wind oh yeah if it
was Breezy absolutely oh really yeah oh
I don't feel what's yours like the
bottom of your foot exactly
cracked like yeah skin on the back of
your heel yes right yeah it's Bert
kreischer's heel
things on that girls that wear heels too
much and get like blisters like if it
ever gets like in rubbing on the zip no
but you can't go oh actually we have
underwear in America yeah yeah but I was
gonna say if you go without the
underwear and you catch it on the back
of a zip or something you probably
wouldn't even notice you wouldn't even
notice no no it's still kind of
sensitive but it's not as sensitive as
as you guys for sure cool yeah let's go
back we can compete later on yeah yeah
we'll see which is more yeah we'll just
flick it that'd be good
I'm wondering is mine even that
sensitive that's an interesting one act
that's also another thing like if you
don't get hard
don't feel bad about it blame the Jews
oh because you desensitized me exactly
like this part of the Jewish conspiracy
to give me erectile dysfunction Kanye
Kanye talk to us you've missed one yeah
we call it Whiskey it's not whiskey it's
yamaka yeah
that is good
that is good see how Comedy Works guys
this is fun
now if I wasn't a comedian it's just two
guys committing a hate crime on a
podcast
I've got the light I've got the light
above us thank you thank you very much
thank you in other news I've got to tell
you about athletic greens you are not
eating enough fruit and vegetables in
your diet and you know it and this is
going to help Dr Andrew human and Tim
Ferriss have been harping on about it
for years and I always wondered why it
is the best green strength that I found
and I've tried pretty much everyone it
tastes great and it gives you
nutritional insurance through 75
vitamins minerals and Whole Food sourced
ingredients in one scoop that you take
every single day if you're starting the
new year looking to give yourself some
good nutritional improvements this is a
great place to begin and there is a
60-day money-back guarantee so you can
buy it and try it for 59 days and if you
do not like it they will give you your
money back also you get a Year's free
Supply vitamin D five free travel packs
free pots shakers and that 60 day money
back guarantee head to
athleticgreens.com wisdom that's
athleticgreens.com slash wisdom what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]